this is gonna be a bit of a bold
statement but I personally believe the
coronavirus has allowed people to play
the lazy card what's going on guys my
name is David Tomich and welcome back to
the channel today we're talking about
the 2019 MacBook Pro versus the 2020
MacBook Pro and why I believe Apple has
copped out on developing what could have
been such a great product 20/20 should
have been one of the biggest years for
technology it was lined up to be a
history-making a decade 2019 set the
standard in folding tech and new gadgets
that we'd never seen before
if 2020 were to play out the correct way
without the global pandemic we probably
would have seen a much bigger demand and
a much greater leap in technology this
year unfortunately it has given people
with the opportunity to sit back and go
know from a business point of view we're
not going to put the best products out
there in the market we're not going to
make sure we are the leaders in the
industry instead we're going to take a
step back and go people are gonna buy
our stuff because that's who we are this
is my belief for the 2020 MacBook Pro
anyway especially when you compare the
base model 2020 to the base model 2019
so one of the most interesting features
about a new MacBook Pro is what happens
to the pricing model how Apple decides
where it's going to place it in the rank
of all its other products if we take a
look at the last decade of macbook
pricing we're gonna see a very
interesting graph appear so in 2010 the
MacBook Pro came in at seventeen hundred
and ninety nine Australian dollars or
eleven ninety nine USD it followed that
trend in 2011 and 2012 as well but in
2012 it introduced a Retina display as
well which bumped it up to sixteen
hundred and ninety nine USD or $24.99
AUD in 2013 it had a huge price bump for
two thousand two hundred and ninety nine
Australian dollars or fourteen hundred
and
99 USD as his base model then drop back
down all of a sudden surprisingly to
nineteen hundred and ninety nine dollars
for the introductory MacBook Pro 13 inch
model in 2015 it kept this price point
until 2016 they introduced the touch bar
it left back up to two thousand two
hundred and ninety nine Australian
dollars for the model without the touch
bar or 2699 with the touch bar when 2018
came in they started phasing out the
touch bar secretly by introducing the
two model system so the model without
the touch bar dropped to one thousand
nine hundred and ninety nine dollars but
the model with the touch bar remained
the same price at two thousand six
hundred and ninety nine dollars in 2019
we saw that price nosedive a little bit
because they removed the secondary
option without the touch bar and it led
to a price point of 1999 Australian
starting which is what it is today in
2020 it's interesting to note how the
economic periods have affected this
company and how it's affected their
starting price we've started at
seventeen hundred and ninety nine
dollars for their flagship top of the
range peaked out at two thousand three
hundred for their entry up model and
then drop back down to 1999 so a laptop
now a flagship laptop which has most of
the parts from a year ago model is still
the same price as a year ago is model
that gets me into the topic and theme of
this video today the 2019 MacBook Pro
and the 2020 20 MacBook Pro are very
similar devices from a base model point
of view both have the touch bar and
touch ID as standard both have an Intel
i5 core processor
as standard both have the 13 inch screen
as standard both have the Retina display
eight gigabytes of RAM two Thunderbolt
three ports and ten hours of battery
life as standard where they start to
differentiate is the 2020 model offers
more storage as standard than the 2019
model so instead of having to purchase
the upgraded model with two hundred and
56 gigabytes versus the 128 gigabytes is
standard in the 2019 model the 2020
model now comes with 256 gigabytes of
storage as standard the 2020 model is
for some reason 0.7 millimeters thicker
than the 2019 model and 30 grams heavier
than the 2019 model this isn't a very
significant difference you probably
won't notice this in day-to-day life so
it wouldn't be something that I would go
and say I know it's a huge difference
don't buy it from this fact now one of
the biggest and best changes to this
keyboard is a simple fact they've
reintroduced the Escape key as a
physical button if you're somebody like
me who hits that button at least a
million times a day it is definitely a
nice inclusion to see in the 2020
MacBook Pro where it does start to get a
little bit different and where it does
start to justify a new model and new
introduction is the simple change in the
keyboard setup the 2020 MacBook Pro
comes with a scissor switch keyboard
setup this is the old butterfly switch
keyboard if you've used a 20-19 or
previous MacBook Pro you're going to
notice that the keyboard isn't too nice
to use and it feels like you just happen
on aluminium the whole time whereas the
new 2020 MacBook keyboard has your
traditional scissor switches which feels
like it has a little bit more travel and
is a nicer product at the end of the day
the difference between scissor switches
and butterfly switches is scissor
switches do what you think there's two
little plastic blades inside that go up
and down as the key pushes versus
butterfly switches which do the opposite
like butterfly wings do now if you were
to walk into a shop today and see the
2019 MacBook Pro and the 2020 MacBook
Pro side-by-side at the exact same price
you would definitely purchase the
brand-new 2020 model thanks to the
upgrade of the keyboard but on the other
hand if you were to walk into that store
and the 2019 model was significantly
discounted which it's more than likely
going to be and you are okay with
how that keyboard feels then personally
in my opinion I would definitely go with
the 2019 MacBook Pro because it's an
identical machine
there isn't any major changes except
that keyboard that is going to throw you
off that's all from me today guys thank
you so much for watching and more
importantly thank you so much for
subscribing yesterday we hit 2,000
subscribers on the channel it isn't a
lot but it's a lot more than we started
with so thank you so much
it really means a lot to me and as
always I'll see you next Monday